well the bts takeover has begun just
ahead of their first sold out show which
is tomorrow marquees all over the strip
as you can see here they turned purple
which is the k-pop group's color
representation of love now the night
culminated with the debut of a new
fountain show at the bellagio
[Music]
the new display using some of the
group's biggest hits like butter and
dynamite
mgm resorts planning to keep those songs
in heavy rotation as the so-called bts
army is expected to be in town over the
weekend and into next week by the way
tomorrow is the first of four sold out
shows that are happening at allegiant
stadium
fans of the group showed up in full
force today looking to get some swag
before the shows begin tomorrow some
lined up outside of the tent at
allegiant stadium at 2 a.m
fans say they look at most of the items
as collectibles
many also planning to check out some of
the themed pop-up spots on and off the
strip over the next few days
who knew what are these kids going to
get a break you know if they only could
find some success goodness gracious
they're taking over our town four days
sold out shows that allegiance
exciting for those fans